that's right move over Angus MacGyver I
really got nothing after that macGruber
okay so so far this movies gotten some
pretty solid buzz we're not the poster
it even says this movie's the funniest
SNL movie since Wayne's World I mean to
be honest that's like saying Revenge of
the Sith is the greatest Star Wars movie
since Empire I mean it's kind of look at
what's come out in between except Return
of the Jedi but it did heavy walks but I
will admit macGruber is way better than
it should be I mean I genuinely laughed
out loud like a few times in the movie
it shouldn't be that good I mean there's
some parts offensive yeah but even in
the offensive parts you still laugh and
that's something so as we all know
macGruber is an SNL spoof or the show
MacGyver do you remember MacGyver you
know the guy who makes something out of
nothing like makes EMP grenades out of
shoelaces love that yeah and I'll be the
first to admit I have not seen him a
gruber anything at a point SNL kind of
became lame so I haven't seen it in a
while except for on the Superbowl
commercial a couple years ago that was
my macGruber experience a commercial on
the Superbowl but I personally love this
movie so apparently you don't have to be
some macGruber SNL veteran to get this
movie it's funny even for we people who
are macGruber virgins so the villain in
this movie is Val Kilmer yeah I guess a
decade and a half later Batman has
become one puffy bastard but he was
hilarious in this movie to kind of like
in real genius only meaner and his name
in macGruber is [ __ ] yeah let the jokes
roll he has hijacked a nuke and the
government can only turn to one man to
stop him
macGruber I gotta admit even after this
movie was over and I was on the road
driving home I was still laughing this
is the funniest movie of 2010 for sure
there been a couple that I liked I found
them funny but this one this is the king
for sure and I emphasize that it's funny
more than I do the plot because the
point of the movie isn't the plot the
point is that it's funny that it makes
you laugh there are a couple times in
the movie where it reuses a joke you
know how recycle jokes is kind of lose
their luster so there is that but it
doesn't take away from like the other 88
minutes that you're laughing so it's
still alright
none of the characters really annoyed me
I mean but I mean to be honest it's a
spoof comedy it's not really to be taken
too seriously like someone was talking
with me they were like if MacGyver never
existed the macGruber wouldn't be funny
first of all yeah it would be second of
all we live in a world where MacGyver
did exist so
it is funny do you want to keep looking
for a parallel universe in which
MacGyver didn't exist by all means go
for it maybe macGruber is less funny in
that parallel universe that doesn't
exist except in fringe but shocker
MacGyver and macGruber do exist in this
reality so macGruber is funny the jokes
were absolute money the last kept coming
and it was the funniest SNL movie since
Wayne's World I mean is macGruber for
everyone probably not if crudeness
offends you or if you're a fan of Coen
Brothers movies you'll probably just
walk out but if you like good comedic
timing laughing out loud and you don't
mind crudeness that makes you laugh like
this then I personally think you'll love
it so I say go check it out probably
because I'm a sick bastard and if you
like what you've seen here then you can
see my other videos and maybe subscribe
by clicking here
[Music]